[Music]
foreign
African countries have been struggling
to get covert vaccines
and when they do not every shot is
always used
in May Malawi and South Sudan had to
destroy thousands of AstraZeneca doses
after they expired and not everyone
wants to get the Jab
there are some who think that this
vaccine will make them important that
some will still believe that these
vaccines will either kill them quick so
it's a big challenge to us
not everyone is convinced covet is real
despite the news
some say the risks are exaggerated
and then there's the legacy of unethical
medical research on the continent that
has left many wary of Western medicine
about two percent of the African
population has been fully vaccinated
against covert so far vaccine access is
the biggest problem skepticism is also a
challenge
here's our correspondent Aryan Krish
reporting from Malawi
people are lining up again outside the
vaccination centers in blantire there's
been a new vaccine delivery
because case numbers have been
increasing in recent weeks so has
people's willingness to get jabbed
compare that to just a few months ago
when Malawi had to incinerate almost 20
000 unused AstraZeneca doses that had
passed their expiry date
vaccine hesitancy is still widespread
even right outside one of the
vaccination centers
because
we are operating our business within
here at Queen Elizabeth central hospital
because and I remember that I've been
feeling some headache for the past three
four months but I just praying to
almighty God some other people they were
saying that there were some other side
effects of their vaccine so in fact I
decided to wait and see first before I
get vaccinated no at the moment I'm not
ready to get it the reason is because
there has been so much rumors about the
convey the coveted vaccine so right now
I'm not sure whether to do to go for it
or not what kind of rumors the negative
like you know we're gonna die after some
after two years
they're going to surprise us stuff like
that
and where did you get this kind of
rumors uh on the social media
but medical experts are hopeful that
vaccine skepticism will eventually be
overcome on the continent as the higher
percentage of your population get
vaccinated less the the has the
hesitancy decrease because people can
see that other people that have been
vaccinated yeah they they are okay I
don't expect in South Africa to have a
big problem because we had very severe
wave and people tend to want to be
vaccinated when they have seen the
severity of the infections for other
countries that didn't have severe
infections rates yeah maybe a little bit
more skepticism back in blantire many of
those waiting for their vaccine are also
optimistic that people will eventually
accept that the jab is in their best
interest
I'm not valid I'm feeling comfortable
just because I get the protection
covered vaccine is there to protect
people
it's not there to kill people in fact
the authorities what he's about to do is
to sensitize people go in The Villages
have some community meeting tell them
the truth of what is there because
sometimes you know the social media is
the one that is peddling a lot of lies
but there's still a lot of convincing to
be done fewer than one percent of all
malawians are fully vaccinated
Charles wesonga is director of the South
African Cochrane Center at the South
African medical research Council in Cape
Town what's your explanation for the
fact that only two percent of Africans
are fully vaccinated against covert
yeah thank you so much uh Ben for having
me I'm happy to know that I'm part of
the two percent I got my covid-19
vaccination because I know that it is
the right thing to do I need access to
yeah thank you
not everybody in Africa has done luxury
because access to covid-19 vaccines in
Africa is still a big issue in many
countries
when you say it's uh it's the biggest
challenge how much is hesitancy playing
a part in skepticism as we heard in that
report uh whether or not the Africans
have access to this vaccine it's then
comes down to a choice of whether or not
they're going to take it and and that
choice is sometimes based on social
media as we heard
yeah there's a lot of rumor going on on
social media so vaccines are a great
asset and vaccination serves lives but
vaccines would only save lives if people
take them if they are taken up and we
have seen that while access is a big
problem in Africa in most countries
That vaccine hesitancy is also a major
challenge in various surveys that have
been done
in Africa you see the proportion of
people who say that they are uncertain
whether they will take the vaccine or
they would uh or those who already said
that they will not take it it varies
somewhere between 50 percent and maybe
15 percent in depending on the country
and at times it changes from time to
time in one study that we've just done
in a in South Africa a national study we
found that 14 percent of people say that
they will not take the vaccine about six
percent are not sure whether they will
take or not and about six percent said
they might likely refuse and 18 percent
are unsure so quite a light proportion
of people who have various degrees of
indecision and uncertainty about
covid-19 vaccines and that would make us
not to achieve head immunity if we only
go with the people who are now accepting
so we still have quite a lot to do you
can't blame Africans though can you I
mean
um this sentiment is based on the
tradition of vaccines having been tested
in the west and then given to Africans
miners the research in Africa
yeah I think I agree with you you know
in addition to that you know when let me
just take one example there was in about
April last year when there was a
discussion on in one French television
there were some scientists some doctors
I hope who were saying that vaccinations
should be tested in Africa because
Africans will not have access to mass
when you have such derogatory remarks
then you would understand why people are
skeptical about the west and there have
been some studies some research scandals
in either in Africa or related to people
of African descents so you would
understand that people can be skeptical
but that does not justify the fact that
when facts are presented to people they
should refuse them so how do you
convince the hesitant or undecided parts
of the population because here we have a
vaccine that's been proven to work
um I know I just got my antibody test
done recently and I've got a super
response
no thank you congratulations
thank you
so what you couldn't even say to people
I mean besides the positive reports you
get from people like me or you how do
you convince people to take the jack
I think those specific stories are very
important that people can see because of
the various rumors they have heard that
there are people who have taken them and
they are healthy and the the risk of
getting the disease is now low and when
you get information about places where
people have been vaccinated and the rate
of disease has gone down and people who
are getting severe disease they are only
very very few of them while in places
where the vaccination rate is not high
you still continue to have a lot of
cases and people are dying they are
getting hospitalized giving that
information is is important and also it
would also be important there are some
influential people in society
faith-based organizations religious
leaders they tend to be nurses that
people go to doctors in the in the
people's local communities I think we
used to we need to have such a local
Champions who can spread the news to
people give the facts develop vaccine
has uh you know vaccine hesitances
sometimes can't because people don't
understand a lot about vaccines because
of these rumors so if we can increase
vaccine literacy give the right
information use the right people to give
the information have uh venues within
communities where people can go to for
information also Enlighten the local
authorities give them the information so
that they can speak with an
authoritative voice Charles person
director of the South African Cochrane
Center sorry I'll have to leave it there
thanks for talking to us today okay
thank you okay have a nice day over to
Derek now DW science correspondent has
been looking into your questions on the
Coronavirus
[Music]
what is the immunological status of
people who've had covid-19 compared to
those who've been vaccinated
in most countries including here in
Germany authorities are treating people
who've been vaccinated and people who've
recovered from the disease as pretty
much the same when it comes to drafting
covid regulations and measures but of
course in immunological terms they
aren't however
because the course of the disease is
unique and every patient who contracts
the virus just look at the range of
possible disease severity actually
trying to to quantify immunological
status in previously infected patients
is a really tricky task with other
diseases experts say immunity acquired
through infection is often more robust
than that acquired through vaccination
but that isn't a blanket rule tetanus
vaccines for example provide longer and
more powerful immunity to the disease
than infection with the bacteria does
and increasingly the evidence indicates
that as Anthony fauci said back in May
covid-19 vaccines provoke a better
immune response than the one provoked by
infection
that's underlined for example by a
recent media statement released by the
CDC in the U.S which Drew on data from a
study involving people in the state of
Kentucky it found that those who'd been
infected and didn't get vaccinated
afterwards that they were more than
twice as likely to be re-infected as
someone who did
put simply the vaccine really improved
protection even in those who'd already
been infected and probably thought that
they didn't need it which is why many
national authorities say you should get
vaccinated even if you had covid-19 and
recovered
[Music]
stay safe
[Music]